être femme c'est pas simplement être
sexuel est certaine façon c'est être
tracé de telle manière de la société
[Musique]
c'était une étude impartiale et très
détaché à un sens et je n'ai pas lu tous
indiquent comme un défi ce qui fait qu
ensuite les réactions masculine que j'ai
eu à ce livre m'ont souvent complètement
stupéfaite parce que je ne m'y attendais
pas du tout
[Musique]
c'est si merveilleux de vous avoir ici
dans ma ferme car vous êtes mon héroïne
depuis que j'ai 20 ans le deuxième sexe
a été quelque chose de fantastique car
il disait tout ce que l'on savait
inconsciemment et personne ne l'avait
encore
[Musique]
ça a été une bombe une bombe à
retardement qui n'en finit pas
d'exploser et qui explosera encore
longtemps parce que le féminisme est
loin d'être acquis actuellement il ya un
retour en arrière qui montre bien à quel
point c'est toujours aussi virulent donc
le deuxième sexe a été le la fusée de
lancement sur vous
simone de beauvoir à forcer les femmes à
reprendre en main leur destin
autrement dit elle leur a expliqué par
cette formule lapidaire le biologique
n'est pas suffisant pour déterminer
votre destin vous avez le choix est par
exemple vous pouvez être une femme à
part entière réussi sans être mère
[Musique]
même si ce livre à 50 ans elle était
tellement en avance sur son temps elle a
eu tellement d'audace dans sa pensée
anti naturaliste qu'elle a vraiment posé
des problèmes qui restent complètement
actuelle la question de l'indépendance
de la liberté du corps de la liberté
sexuelle
[Musique]